here's what would happen if you didn't  pee for a week  after the first 10 hours you'd  experience urinary retention you  couldn't go pee even if you wanted to  after a day it would hurt to move you'd  experience the beginning of a bladder  infection within three days if your  infection kept spreading you might  develop hydronephrosis this is the  swelling of your kidneys after urine  builds up it could cause a reverse flow  sending pee into your liver you'd have  nausea fever and potentially loss of  bladder control you might wind up in a  hospital after one week your prostate is  swelling up if you have one and your  bladder might change position you would  pee out liters of urine if they could  get through the blockage you might need  dialysis or even a new kidney which in  the United States would put you on a  four year long wait list so